what's the address of the emergency sign
hello hi sir listen permits are already
on the way I have no idea where they're
at right now Lisa Marie Presley died
last week after going into cardiac
arrest at her LA area home now a newly
released 9-1-1 call gives fans insight
into her final hours
is there someone else there with you
right now
okay can you hand him the phone because
I can hear him a little bit better than
I can hear you hi hello hi sir listen
very much are you on the way so that
they need to get in there
uh no there's a security gate on the
neighborhood but I'll just let them
through okay Ken okay just want to make
sure I have the right location Lisa
Marie's housekeeper and a man believed
to be her ex-husband Danny Keough can be
heard frantically communicating with the
9-1-1 operator in the call that was
obtained and released by the New York
Post on Tuesday the singer-songwriter
was taken to the hospital where her
heart reportedly stopped several times
before she was pronounced dead
I have no idea where they're at right
now so over I think they're here are
they there with you
all right thank you the New York Post
says that her ex Danny who was living
with her at the time attempted to
perform CPR until EMTs arrived and
according to reports emergency
responders revived Lisa Marie several
times before her death an official cause
of death has yet to be determined
a public memorial service for Elvis and
Priscilla Presley's only daughter has
been scheduled on the front lawn of
Graceland at 9am on Sunday she'll be
laid to rest at the Memphis estate next
to her son Benjamin Keough who died by
suicide in 2020 at age 27. a rep for
Lisa Marie confirmed to E.T on Tuesday
that Graceland will be handed down to
her daughters 33-year-old Riley Keough
and 14 year old twins herper and Finley
Lockwood they love it there so they just
love it and
love the golf carts love the horses and
love eating there and love their family
they love their family they have cousins
there and stuff so they love that
time of her death Lisa Marie was still
the sole owner of Elvis's Memphis
mansion and its 13 acre grounds she sold
off most of the Elvis estate in 2004 but
kept the family home it's absolutely 100
mine always has been mine Graceland
always will be and when it's no longer
mine it would be my children's you know
that's that Lisa Marie shares her
teenage daughters with her ex-husband
Michael Lockwood after a contentious
split Lisa Marie had custody of the
girls 60 of the time while Michael had
them the remaining 40. the court is
going to look at the fact that the
biological parent should have at the
very least 100 legal custody
the ability to make all of the important
decisions in the children's lives a
source close to Michael tells ET that as
of now he has full legal and physical
custody of his daughters quote the girls
are Michael's top priority all everyone
wants are Smiles on the girls faces
foreign
[Music]